the warden's defeat is a great victory
for us nay for all of humankind but
there are many more ethereals out there
some much more powerful than craig
perhaps more disturbing though
there are those of our own kind who
would see us dead to take what little we
have or just for the pleasure of killing
among the innocent who passed through
this prison on their way to krieg's lab
were many violent criminals murderers
and worse
many of them escaped to the northwest
after the grim dawn forming into
ruthless gangs who prey upon drifters
still traveling the roads
since a river separates us and them they
have not been a problem thus far
except we need farmers to get back to
the business of growing food before we
all starve to death
the farmland that supplied this region
is to the northwest and we need to
secure a hold there
mornay recently returned from old
arkovia to the northwest and can give
you details on the outlaw situation
and what needs to be done
i realize that you have been through
much in recent days
i trust that you are handling everything
all right
so you must be the kid that's causing a
stir in my absence
you've done good by dispatching creek
i knew that man in life i dread to think
of what he had become as an ethereal
i an old mess has come back to finally
bite us right in the ass
the rivers kept them at bay for now what
with the broken bridge
it seems the bastards have garnered a
taste for the one hole in the with a
bridge northwest repaired i need you to
enter the arkovian foothills and show
those bastards were not a prize for the
taking
last i saw them they were
kill the warden eh so one bastard killed
another makes little just keeping my
good eye on the top
cut off
uh
ugh
[Music]
uh
well
do they like our housewarming gift you
work fast i like that we'll need more of
that for what's coming next darius
cronley